GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME AT THIS
TIME, WE WILL CONVENE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. I WANT TO NOTE FOR
THE RECORD, FOR EVERYONE
PRESENT. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION, WE HAVE 127
ISSUES TO DISPOSE WITH IN THE
VOTE ITEM CALENDAR DOCKET TODAY,
FOR THE RECORD, ALL OF THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE BEING
VOTED ON ARE NOTED IN THE STAFF
REPORT ON EACH AND SEPARATE
ITEMS, APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
PARTICIPATION. ANYONE WHO
DESIRES TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY TO
THE SUBCOMMITTEE, PLEASE MAKE
YOUR WAY TO ROOM 113 HERE IN THE
CAPITOL, BECAUSE THAT WILL BE
WHAT OUR HEARING CONSISTS OF
TODAY IS YOUR IMPORTANT
TESTIMONY. AND AT THIS TIME, I
WOULD ASK THE CONSULTANT TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SENATORS
PADILLA PRESENT NILO HERE.
CUEVAS HERE. WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU. I WANT TO THANK FIRST
AND FOREMOST OUR AMAZING
COMMITTEE STAFF, BOTH AT THE SUB
AND MORE BROADLY, WITHOUT THEIR
WORK AND DEDICATION, THOSE OF US
TASKED WITH THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF MAKING SOME OF THESE CALLS
WOULD NEVER GET IT DONE, AND IT
WOULD NEVER ULTIMATELY,
HOPEFULLY BENEFIT, THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
HAS BEEN A TOUGH YEAR WITH A LOT
OF CHALLENGES AND NOT EASY
DECISION MAKING TO MAKE SURE WE
HOPE THAT WE END UP IN A
SITUATION AND A FRAMEWORK, WHICH
I THINK WE ARE WELL ON THE WAY
TO DOING TO PROTECT. CERTAINLY
THE MOST VULNERABLE, THE MOST
UNDER-INVESTED, THE MOST LEAST
ACCESSED FOLKS IN OUR, IN OUR,
IN OUR STATE AND WHILE WE HAVE A
LOT OF, STUFF TO VOTE ON TODAY
THAT DEALS WITH SHIFTING FUNDS,
DELAYING IMPLEMENTATION, AN
INCREASED REVENUE BORROWING, AND
OTHER WAYS TO TRY TO GET AT THE
DEFICIT THAT WE'RE FACING. I
WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE THAT THE
SCOPE OF BUDGET SUB FOUR IS
DEFINITIVE AND DEFINED. AND YOU
KNOW WHAT? THAT IS, BUT IT IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE OVERALL
BUDGET AGREEMENT FRAMEWORK IN
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THAT I
THANK OUR LEADERSHIP FOR PRO TEM
AND THE BUDGET CHAIRS IN BOTH
HOUSES, THAT IS AN IMPORTANT
PIECE OF THAT OVERALL FRAMEWORK
THAT LETS US CONTINUE TO PROTECT
THOSE THINGS THAT I THINK ALL OF
US AS CALIFORNIANS, BELIEVE ARE
VERY, VERY IMPORTANT, WE HAVE
SOME CHALLENGES, BUT WE ARE
ENDEAVORING, TO MAKE THOSE
CHALLENGES. AND SO, AGAIN, THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION.
THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE SUB AND THANK YOU, OF
COURSE, TO OUR AMAZING STAFF,
AND WITH THAT, BEFORE WE PROCEED
TO TAKING COMMENT, I WOULD
INVITE MY FELLOW SUB MEMBERS, IF
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS TO PUT AND
SENATOR NILO AND SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. WELL, WE KNOW IT'S
WORKING. SOMEBODY DOESN'T WANT
ME TO SPEAK MORE THAN ONE
PERSON. JUST A LITTLE EARLY FOR
THAT. I SEE I HAVE MY FAN BASE
HERE, I'LL ECHO WHAT THE CHAIR
SAID, AND I MAKE THE SOMEWHAT
FRUSTRATING OBSERVATION THAT, I,
I LEFT HERE HAVING SERVED SIX
YEARS IN THE ASSEMBLY IN 2010
WITH A HORRIBLE BUDGET, IT WAS
MUCH WORSE THE YEAR BEFORE WE
WENT THROUGH SIMILAR EXERCISES
AS NOW, ALTHOUGH IT WAS A MORE
SERIOUS ISSUE, BUT NONETHELESS,
I, I WENT OUT WITH A LOUSY
BUDGET SITUATION, AND I COME
BACK IN WITH A LOUSY BUDGET
SITUATION. LAST YEAR, SENATE
LAIRD, WHO WAS CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE WHILE
I WAS VICE CHAIR, OPINED THAT
THAT COINCIDENCE BEING THE CASE,
HE SAID THAT IT WAS MY FAULT,
IT'S NOT, BUT AT ANY RATE, AS I
SAID, I ECHO WHAT THE CHAIR
SAID, BUT I WANT TO ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE, THE VALUABLE ROLE
THAT THE LADY SITTING TO MY LEFT
PLAYS. SHE, BRIEFS ME ON EVERY
SESSION AND PROVIDES VALUABLE
KNOWLEDGE AND ADVICE. AND I HAVE
APPRECIATED THAT VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. WHOA NOT JUST YOU,
SIR. SENATOR SMALLWOOD, THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND I WANT TO
ECHO COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
ABOUT THE SUPPORT OF THE STAFF
AND HELPING US NAVIGATE THIS
DIFFICULT TIME. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY, I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE WHO CAME AND TESTIFIED
TO THIS COMMITTEE, WHETHER IT
WAS PROTECTING SMALL BUSINESS
TECHNOLOGY, TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
, SUPPORT CALIFORNIA COMPETES,
WHETHER IT WAS MAKING SURE THAT,
YOU KNOW, WE HAD STRONG
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS IN PLACE
THAT CONTINUE TO BE FUNDED,
WHETHER IT WAS MAKING SURE THAT,
WE DID ALL THAT WE CAN TO
PROTECT THE GOVERNMENT SERVICES
AND OPERATIONS THAT REALLY
MATTER TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA, MANY OF YOU CAME AND
SPENT HOURS IN COMMITTEE WITH US
EXPLAINING NOT JUST THAT THE
CUTS SHOULDN'T HAPPEN, BUT WHAT
THE IMPACT OF THE CUTS WILL BE.
THIS WAS A VERY DIFFICULT BUDGET
. WE STARTED AT A $70 BILLION
DEFICIT AND I KNOW THE SENATE
HAS WORKED EXTREMELY HARD TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE BALANCE THIS
BUDGET, BUT NOT ON THE BACKS OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. WE STILL HAVE WORK
TO DO. WE STILL HAVE TO, CONVEY
THIS, THE ADMINISTRATION TO
STAND WITH US ON THIS BUDGET,
BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY, THANK
YOU, IT WAS BECAUSE OF THOSE
TESTIMONIES AS THE DATA AND THE
ANALYSIS THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
MAKE, THE DECISIONS THAT WE
WERE, COMFORTABLE WITH MAKING
BECAUSE OF THE INPUT THAT YOU
SHARED TO HELP US PRIORITIZE. SO
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS, THOSE ADVOCACY
GROUPS, FOR YOUR VOICE IN MAKING
SURE WE DO ALL THAT WE CAN TO
KEEP CALIFORNIA WHOLE. SENATOR,
APPRECIATE YOUR VOICE VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. THIS IS HOW WE'LL
PROCEED, I'M GOING TO SEGREGATE
OUT, TWO OF THE ISSUES AMONG THE
127, THOSE BEING ISSUE SEVEN AND
ISSUE 112, THOSE BEING THE
PERFORMING ARTS EQUITABLE
PAYROLL FUND UNDER GO-BIZ AND
UNDER ARTS COUNCIL, THE ARTS
GRANT PROGRAM REDUCTION, BASED
ON THE MAY REVISION SUBMITTED BY
THE GOVERNOR. WE HAVE A VERY,
DISTINGUISHED GUEST HERE TODAY
TO PROVIDE SOME TESTIMONY ON
THESE ISSUES BEFORE US, SOMEONE
WHO'S CAREER IS MORE THAN
DISTINGUISHED AND SET A GREAT
EXAMPLE IN THE ARTS, MR. DANNY
GLOVER, AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
WELCOME HIM HERE AND WELCOME
YOU, SIR, AND GIVE YOU A FEW
MINUTES TO PROVIDE SOME INPUT TO
THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON THESE
MATTERS. AND WELCOME AND PLEASE
PROCEED. WOW I'M SO MANY
THOUGHTS ARE RUNNING THROUGH MY
HEAD, I WANT TO THANK YOU. FIRST
OF ALL, FOR, FOR THE PRIVILEGE
OF BEING HERE ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY ARTISTS ALL OVER THE
STATE. AND CERTAINLY THE
GENEROSITY THAT YOU'VE EXHIBITED
HERE AT THE STATE LEGISLATURE,
LEGISLATOR AND LEGISLATORS, AND
ALSO AS CITIZENS YOURSELF WHO
PROBABLY FIND THEMSELVES GOING
TO THEATERS, COMMUNITY THEATERS
AND BEING SURPRISED AT THE WORK
THAT'S THERE AND IDEA THAT'S
BUTTRESSES. THE WHOLE SYSTEM IS
THE IDEA OF COMMUNITY IS THE
OWNERSHIP OF ALL OF US. I CAME
UP THROUGH, COMMUNITY THEATER.
THERE WERE MOMENTS WHERE, THERE
WAS THE IDEA WASN'T WASN'T
SIMPLY TO FIND IN THE CENTER OF
THE STORY, BUT TO BE A PART OF
THE STORY. AND THEN AND THEN I
REPRESENTED THOSE PEOPLE WHO SAT
IN THOSE AUDIENCES, WHO CAME TO
THOSE PERFORMANCES AND WHO SAW
THEMSELVES IN SOME WAYS
EXEMPLIFIES A VALIDATED ID IN,
IN THAT IN THE PLAYS AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS ABOUT
COMMUNITY ART THAT'S ITSELF,
THAT VALIDATION THAT HAPPENS
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY, THOSE
COMMUNITY PLAYERS THEMSELVES.
AND I, I REMEMBER MY MOTHER AND
THIS DAY IS FROM MY DEAR LOVE OF
SHE CAME TO SEE ME AT THE PALO
ALTO COMMUNITY THEATER, AND SHE
WAS WAITING IN THE, IN THE, IN
THE AFTER THE PERFORMANCE, I WAS
THE I WAS PLAYED LENNY IN MICE
AND MEN AND I THINK HAD BEEN
DONE THE YEAR THE SAME YEAR WITH
JAMES EARL JONES ON ON BROADWAY
AND I PLAYED AND I REMEMBER
COMING UP TO ME NO, SHE, SHE,
SHE LOOKED AROUND. I CAME OUT,
EVERYONE'S GONE. SHE KIND OF
TOOK A SECOND LOOK AROUND AND
SHE LOOKED AT ME AND SHE SAID,
SON, THE PEOPLE SAID, YOU CAN
ACT SO SHE SHE TOOK A SURVEY.
AND THAT BECAME HER MODEL. MY
SON DANNY IS AN ACTOR AND BEFORE
THEY SAY THEY, WELL, WHAT HAS HE
DONE? SHE HASN'T DONE ANYTHING
YET. ONE DAY HE'S GOING TO DO
SOMETHING IMPORTANT. THIS IS THE
ONE DAY THAT'S IMPORTANT THAT I
AM HERE. I APPRECIATE IT SO MUCH
THAT YOU TAKE. ALLOW ME TO BE
AND GIVE SOME BREATH TO THIS
AMAZING PROCESS OF COMMUNITY ART
, WHERE IT COMES ON, WHERE HOW
IT COMES ABOUT, HOW DO PEOPLE
RESET, REIMAGINE THEMSELVES
THROUGH ART AND THAT POSSIBILITY
AND THE HONOR TO BE HERE AND TO
SERVICE THAT AS IT IS, SERVICED
ME THROUGHOUT MY THROUGHOUT MY
CAREER, WHETHER IT'S ROBEY
THEATER, A THEATER COMPANY THAT
I'VE, THAT CO-FOUNDED WITH
BENNETT GUILLORY, WE KNOWN EACH
OTHER SINCE WE WERE HIPPIES
TOGETHER, YOU KNOW, AND THAT'S A
THAT'S A THAT'S A LONG TIME AGO.
BUT SOME OF YOU HERE BUT BUT
THAT THAT THE HONOR TO BE HERE
REPRESENTING THOSE ARTISTS WHO
FEEL IN THEIR HEART THAT THEY'RE
DOING SOMETHING OF VALUE, WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE VALUE. AND
THAT'S WHAT YOU'VE DONE. THAT'S
WHAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
DONE IN EVERY PART OF THIS
STATE. THEY BROUGHT, THEY
ALLOWED PEOPLE TO BRING VALUE
AND LOVE AND IMAGINATION.
IMAGINE WHAT DID EINSTEIN SAID.
IMAGINATION IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN KNOWLEDGE. SO IN IN THOSE
ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
THAT I FEEL GRATEFUL FOR. WHERE
WHEN THE MOMENTS AND THERE'S SO
MANY MOMENTS IN MY LIFE, YOU
KNOW, IN ONE, ONE WOMAN, NELSON
MANDELA, JUST AFTER, RIGHT AFTER
HE BEEN RELEASED, AND HE AND
WINNIE AND I CAME UP TO HIM, HE
SAID, WINNIE, MEET YOUR OTHER
HUSBAND. BECAUSE I HAD PLAYED,
MAN, I HAD PLAYED MANDELA FOR
HBO. AND CHANNEL FOUR YEARS
BEFORE. BEFORE HE WAS WHITE, HE
WAS STILL INCARCERATED. THOSE
ARE THE THANK YOU'S, YOU KNOW,
TO HAVE TO MY MOTHER AND FATHER.
REALLY BECAUSE MY MAMA DIDN'T GO
WITH MOTHER TO COME ON THE
JOURNEY. SHE PASSED AWAY TOO
SOON AND BUT BUT WE, THE TWO MEN
WHO WERE IN LOVE WITH HER MOST,
MYSELF AND MY DAD, WE CELEBRATED
EVERY MOMENT. SO THIS IS FOR
THEM AND FOR THEM. FOR MY. FOR
ALL MY SIBLINGS. YOU KNOW, THE
FIVE OF US AND THE THAT I'VE
BORN CALIFORNIA. I LIVE IN THE
SAME. MY DAD WANTED TO GO BACK
TO DETROIT AFTER HE WAS RELEASED
FROM THE ARMY, AND MY MOTHER
SAID, YOU BETTER FIND A JOB
HERE. WE AIN'T GOING NOWHERE.
THIS IS GOD'S COUNTRY. AND I
STILL I WORKED FOR CITY
GOVERNMENT. I BELIEVE IN CITY
GOVERNMENT. I WAS JUST OUT IN
THE BAYVIEW-HUNTERS POINT WHERE
I WAS A VALUATION SPECIALIST FOR
THE MODEL CITIES PROGRAM IN THE
OFFICE OF COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
IN 1971. JUST NOW MEETING,
MEETING A COUPLE OF PEOPLE THAT
I'VE KNOWN IT IS IT THOSE ARE
THE THINGS THAT THAT ARE
NURTURED FOR ALL THOSE ALL OF US
IN COMMUNITY ART. AND I
CERTAINLY WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING UP THIS AND ENCOURAGE YOU
TO GIVE AS MUCH FUNDING AND AS
MUCH OF YOUR, YOUR, YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE WORK THAT
HAPPENS TO THOUSANDS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE, THOUSANDS OF MEN AND
WOMEN, THOUSANDS WHO, WHO, WHO
WILL NEVER PERHAPS HAVE A POINT
OF AS SOMETHING SHOWN ON
TELEVISION THAT'S WHO WE'RE IN
THE SERVICE OF. AND HOW MUCH JOY
THEY BRING TO THAT. I'LL NEVER
SAY MY MOTHER, IF SHE LOOKED
BACK, SHE SAID, SON, THE PEOPLE
SAID, YOU CAN ACT WELL, SHE
SAID, ANYWAY. AND THAT
EVERYWHERE SHE HAD THOSE GOOD
THINGS. BUT AS THEY SAID THAT
I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE YOU'RE
SAYING DANNY GLOVER LOVES THIS
STATE. HE LOVES THE CITY THAT
HE'S IN. HE LIVED IN AND LIVED
IN ALL HIS LIFE. AND I'M PROUD
TO BE REPRESENTING ALL THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE MAKING THEIR WAY,
THROUGH THE WORK OF BRINGING
LOVE AND COMMUNITY TOGETHER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR. GLOVER.
IT'S AN HONOR TO HAVE YOU HERE
AND YOUR YOUR ADVOCACY OVER THE
YEARS, YOUR EXAMPLE AND YOUR
INPUT IS MORE THAN WELL
RECEIVED. AND I KNOW THAT YOU
LIFT UP YOUR VOICE FOR MANY,
MANY OTHERS WHO CAN'T BE HERE
TODAY. AND SO THANK YOU, SIR,
FOR THAT. VERY, VERY MUCH HONOR
TO HAVE YOU HERE WITH THAT.
THANK YOU. THANKS ALL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. AND WITH THAT, I WILL
ALSO, AS SOON AS WE SETTLE HERE,
I WILL INVITE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS THE SAME TWO ISSUE
ITEMS, ISSUES. SEVEN AND 112,
THAT MR. GLOVER JUST ADDRESSED.
I'LL INVITE ANY ANYONE ELSE WHO
WANTS TO PROVIDE SOME PUBLIC
TESTIMONY ON THOSE MATTERS TO
COME ON UP, LINE UP AT THE MIC
AND STATE YOUR NAME FOR THE
RECORD AND, PROVIDE YOUR
TESTIMONY, IF YOU SO DESIRE, ON
THESE TWO ISSUES. WELL I'M.
THANK YOU. SORRY. SORRY ABOUT
THAT. THANK YOU. SENATORS AND
STAFF. I'M TRACY HUDAK WITH
CALIFORNIA ARTS ADVOCATES AND
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR DEEPEST
APPRECIATION AND UNDERSTANDING
FOR YOUR CARING AND THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH TO THE BUDGET
CHALLENGES. AND WE UNDERSTAND
THE HARD WORK, WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE THAT THIS PLAN WITH
, RESTORES THE FUNDING TO THE
EQUITABLE PAYROLL FUND, AND WE
CELEBRATE WITH YOU THE JOBS THAT
THIS INVESTMENT WILL SUSTAIN
OAN AND THE COMMUNITY VIBRANCY
THAT IT WILL STIMULATE. AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE
PLANNING THIS PLAN INDICATES THE
FUNDING WILL BE RESTORED IN FULL
TO THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
IN THREE YEARS. AND WE GENTLY,
REQUEST, TO RESTORE THE FULL
FUNDING NOW, BECAUSE THE AGENCY
IS CURRENTLY FUNCTIONING AT CUT
LEVEL AND AT $26 MILLION A YEAR,
THAT'S BEEN AT THAT LEVEL FOR
SIX YEARS. IT HASN'T GROWN IN
PARALLEL WITH THE WITH THE
BUDGET, THE STATE BUDGET AND AT
THAT LEVEL, IT'S LITERALLY HALF
ADJUSTING FOR INFLATION,
INFLATION THAN THE AMOUNT THAT
IT WAS FUNDED AT IN 2000. SO WE
AND THIS IS FUNDING THAT REACHES
OUR COMMUNITIES, ESPECIALLY
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO OTHER FUNDING SOURCES.
AND WE REALLY, APPRECIATE YOUR
CAREFUL CONSIDERATION OF THAT
ITEM. AND AND AGAIN, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON BEHALF OF
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. WELCOME. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS TAMARA SANDIFER. I'M THE
FOUNDER AND CEO OF AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED STUDIO TÊ
ARTS AND ENTERTAINMENT. I AM ONE
OF THOSE VULNERABLE PEOPLE FROM
ONE OF THOSE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. I GREW UP IN WEST
OAKLAND AND RICHMOND,
CALIFORNIA. WE DIDN'T HAVE
PEOPLE COMING IN THERE TO TEACH
US THE ARTS, SO WE FOUND
ACTIVITY THAT KEPT US OFF THE
STREETS THROUGH THE ARTS, IN
PARKS AND FREE SPACES. LIKE MR.
GLOVER SAID, WE RELY ON
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS THROUGH THE
ARTS BECAUSE OF WHAT I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THROUGH THE
ARTS. I'M SERVICING IN EXCESS OF
200,000 YOUTH FROM THE TOP OF
CALIFORNIA TO THE BOTTOM. WE
HAVE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT HAVE
FILTERED THROUGH OUR PROGRAM
THAT WORK WITH THE LIKES OF
BEYONCE, CHRIS BROWN, USHER,
RIHANNA, BRITNEY SPEARS,
JENNIFER LOPEZ. THE LIST IS
VERY, VERY LONG. THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT SAME YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT WE FOUND IN COMMUNITIES
WHERE THEY'RE UNDER-RESOURCED,
TECH STARVED. THEY DON'T EVEN
HAVE THEIR BASIC NEEDS BEING MET
. THEY HAVE TO PICK BETWEEN, DO
I BUY FOOD OR DO I BUY
TOOTHPASTE? SO WE PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES FOR THEM. I KNOW WHEN
YOU THINK OF THE ARTS, MOST
PEOPLE THINK OF THINGS THAT WE
CAN HANG ON WALLS AND PLACES WE
CAN GO TO VIEW THINGS THAT HANG
ON WALLS. OR, LIKE MR. GLOVER
MENTIONED, A THEATER. BUT WE
DON'T EVEN HAVE THOSE THINGS. WE
HAVE OUR CLASSES, THE GRASS AND
A PARK AND A BOOM BOX, AND
WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO FEED OUR
KIDS BEFORE WE SEND THEM HOME.
OUR GOAL IN BEING HERE TODAY IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT, YES, WE DO
HAVE. WE ARE KNOWN FOR THE ARTS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA, BUT THERE'S
A DIFFERENT KIND OF ART THAT'S
FEEDING A DIFFERENT KIND OF
PEOPLE, THAT'S CHANGING THEIR
LIVES. SO OUR HOPE IN ME,
REPRESENTING THE 200,000 YOUTH
THAT WE SERVICE NATIONALLY AND
THEIR FAMILIES, IS THAT WE CAN
HAVE A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE ON
HOW THE ARTS ARE SHOWING UP FOR
PEOPLE WHO DESPERATELY NEED A
DIFFERENT CAREER PATHWAY THROUGH
THE ARTS, A WAY TO FEED THEIR
FAMILIES THROUGH THE ARTS, A WAY
TO EDUCATE THEMSELVES
DIFFERENTLY THROUGH THE ARTS.
AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT
FOR 37 YEARS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
I'M A BLACK FEMALE CEO. I'M ON A
FORBES LIST. I'VE BUILT
SOMETHING FROM ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING. I DIDN'T HAVE A SCHOOL
THAT TAUGHT ME HOW TO DO WHAT I
DO. I DIDN'T HAVE A MODEL THAT I
REFERENCED. I SIMPLY WANTED TO
SERVE MY PEOPLE, AND I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO DO THAT THROUGH THE
ARTS, AND IT'S BEEN
TRANSFORMATIVE FOR HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF YOUTH FROM
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. WE ARE SCALING WHAT WE
DO BY WAY OF SERVICE FROM
SACRAMENTO, CALIFORNIA. PEOPLE
COME FROM ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
TO STUDY WHAT WE DO AND APPLY
WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN THEIR STATES.
BLACK WALL STREET IN, IN IN
TULSA, OKLAHOMA, PHILADELPHIA,
HARLEM AND ATLANTA, GEORGIA.
THEY COME HERE TO STUDY US. SO
MY HOPE IS THAT WE'LL RECONSIDER
HOW WE RESHAPE OUR BUDGET. TRUST
ME, I GET IT. I'M A BUDGET
PERSON BECAUSE I HAVE TO MAKE A
DOLLAR OUT OF $0.15 EVERY DAY.
SO I UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING
HERE AS FAR AS MANAGING THE
BUDGET OF OUR STATE. BUT I AM
ASKING THAT YOU RECONSIDER NOT
PULLING RESOURCES AWAY FROM
SOMETHING THAT'S WORKING FOR
PEOPLE LIKE US AND FEEDING THE
REST OF OUR COUNTRY. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS JAMES
ELLISON. I'M THE ARTISTIC
DIRECTOR OF CELEBRATION ARTS,
WHICH IS A THEATER HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. WE HIGHLIGHT THE
BLACK EXPERIENCE THROUGH
STORYTELLING WITH DANCE, MUSIC
AND ACTING. AND NOW VISUAL,
VISUAL AND VISUAL ARTS. FIRST, I
WANT TO THANK YOU GUYS. YOU
KNOW, I KNOW YOU GUYS ARE NOT,
OR YOU GUYS ARE RESTORING THE
FUNDS, BUT ANY CUTS WILL BE IS A
DETRIMENT IS A DETRIMENT, I'M A
PERSON WHO ACTUALLY GREW UP
SOUTH SACRAMENTO, NEIGHBORHOOD
HOOD WASN'T THAT GOOD. I GOT
INTO THE ARTS, AND IT ACTUALLY
SAVED MY LIFE. AND THOSE FUNDS
REALLY HELP US TO SAVE LIVES.
WE'RE ACTUALLY SAVING LIVES.
I'LL ACTUALLY TOOK BEN
GUILLORY'S CLASS, WHICH DANNY
GLOVER, YOU KNOW, IS ARTS
CONNECTS THE WHOLE THE WHOLE
STATE. ARTS CONNECTS. IT'S
CONNECTING EVERYTHING. AND THAT
FUNDS THOSE FUNDS ARE THE WATER
THAT THAT HYDRATE THE ARTS. AND
SO IF YOU GUYS DO ANY CUTS, YOU
GUYS ARE, ARE DEHYDRATING US. SO
ANY ANY CUTS WOULD YOU KNOW,
REALLY NOT HELP, SO I ASK THAT
YOU GUYS PLEASE, RECONSIDER, ANY
OF THOSE CUTS TO THE CAC? THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY. MY
NAME IS ROBERT VAN. I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
SACRAMENTO YOUTH SYMPHONY HERE,
AND THE ARTISTIC DIRECTOR OF THE
LIGHT OPERA THEATER, SACRAMENTO.
AND I WANT TO PARROT EXACTLY
WHAT, WHAT JAMES WAS JUST
SAYING. I KNOW YOU HAVE A LOT OF
HARD, DECISIONS TO MAKE, AND I'M
CERTAINLY NOT AS ELOQUENT AS
MISS TÊ. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE. AND, I JUST WANTED
TO SAY THE SACRAMENTO YOUTH
SYMPHONY IS, SUCH A WONDERFUL,
ASSET TO THIS COMMUNITY. WE HAVE
OVER 400 KIDS THAT PARTICIPATE
IN OUR IN OUR PROGRAMS, NOT
COUNTING OUR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS THAT WE THAT WE OFFER
FREE TO KIDS IN UNDERREPRESENT
COMMUNITIES. I CAN TELL YOU I'M
A PRODUCT OF A SIMILAR PROGRAM
DOWN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA,
WHERE I GREW UP. AND I'M JUST SO
GRATEFUL FOR THAT KIND OF
EDUCATION. AND JUST LIKE JAMES
SAID, THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
PIECE OF EDUCATION. AND IT'S
REALLY LIFE CHANGING. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR ALL THE WORK YOU ARE
DOING. I UNDERSTAND I DO NOT
ENVY WHAT YOU'RE DOING, AND THE
DECISIONS YOU HAVE TO MAKE. BUT,
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO US.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING THE
ARTS. NOT AS A SECONDARY OPTION.
AND, WE WISH YOU WELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. AS TO
THOSE TWO ISSUE ITEMS, ANYONE
ELSE WANT TO ADDRESS A SUB ON
THAT? IF NOT, WHAT WE WILL DO IS
, IS, GO AHEAD AND TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE BALANCE OF ALL
THE OTHER NOTICED ISSUES WHICH
ARE, YOU KNOW, 125 AND YOU ARE
MOST WELCOME. A SUBCOMMITTEE IS
INTERESTED IN YOUR TESTIMONY. GO
AHEAD AND LINE UP HERE AT THE
MIC, I DON'T HAVE YET A SENSE.
AND I'LL ASK THE SERGEANTS. WE
MAY HAVE A NUMBER OF SPEAKERS,
BUT IN THE INTEREST OF TIME,
BECAUSE WE HAVE MANY, MANY
SPEAKERS, POTENTIALLY. PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD.
TRY TO LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT
A MINUTE, AND WE'LL TRY TO GET
MAKE SURE EVERYBODY HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY. AND WITH THAT
WELCOME. YES. THANK YOU. SENATOR
LARA KAMLAGER WITH NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS, CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND
WE WANT TO THANK YOU. THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR SUPPORTING THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
AND ALL THE SMALL BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA, I PROMISED THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS THAT WE
WOULD KEEP OUR TESTIMONY
LIMITED. AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT HAVE COME
TO SACRAMENTO TO THANK YOU.
TODAY, WE HAVE ALSO GENERATED
ABOUT 2500 LETTERS THAT WE WILL
BE SENDING TO THE GOVERNOR, IN
TO ASK FOR HIS SUPPORT OF THE
TAP FUNDING. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS PAT NOGHAI.
I AM THE LEADER OF THE LOS
ANGELES REGIONAL SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER NETWORK, THE
SBDC, ALSO THE LEADER OF THE LOS
ANGELES REGIONAL VETERANS
BUSINESS OUTREACH CENTER, THE
VIDAK. I'M A VETERAN MYSELF AND
A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER MYSELF. I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE SENATE
LEADERSHIP FOR YOUR SUPPORT, FOR
RESTORING FUNDING TO THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM,
THE TAP FUNDS. THESE ARE
INVALUABLE FUNDS AND WOULD ALLOW
US, ALONG WITH OUR COUNTERPARTS
IN THE STATE, TO OFFER SMALL
BUSINESS TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
ASSIST OVER 150,000 BUSINESSES
EACH YEAR, MOST OF THOSE BEING
FEMALE OWNED AND BIPOC. SO
AGAIN, THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR
SUPPORT. WE REALLY APPRECIATE
IT. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS BENJAMIN PRATT. I OWN
KESTREL AERIAL IMAGING OUT OF
YUBA COUNTY, ALSO A VETERAN
OWNED BUSINESS, TOGETHER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION. THE SBDC HAS
BEEN FANTASTIC WITH HELPING ME
TAKE AN IDEA AND TURN IT INTO AN
ACTUAL BUSINESS, THE AID THAT
THEY'VE GIVEN ME SO FAR HAS BEEN
INVALUABLE. AND I WOULD NOT HAVE
EVEN STARTED MY BUSINESS WITHOUT
THE KIND OF SUPPORT THAT THEY
WERE ABLE TO GIVE ME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HI, MY NAME IS
ARISTOTLE JONES, MY COMPANY IS
GSE GENERAL ENGINEERING INC. I'M
A SMALL CIVIL CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACTING COMPANY, I STARTED
WORKING WITH THE SBDC ABOUT FOUR
MONTHS AGO, WITH THEIR HELP,
THEY'VE AIDED ME IN, REGISTERING
FOR THE FEDERAL SYSTEM OF AWARDS
MANAGEMENT, AND THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES,
THEY HELPED ME STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS OF GETTING REGISTERED
CORRECTLY SO THAT I DIDN'T
MISREPRESENT MY COMPANY. SO I
CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE PUBLIC
FUNDS, TO BID ON PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS, I INTEND TO CONTINUE
TO USE THE SBDC RESOURCES TO
GROW MY BUSINESS SO THAT I CAN,
WIN PROJECTS, BUILD PUBLIC
WORKS, AND PROVIDE JOBS FOR THE
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS RAFEAL.
I JUST COME TO US, LIKE, TWO
YEARS AGO FROM AFGHANISTAN
THROUGH A SPECIAL IMMIGRATION
VISA. AND LAST YEAR, JUST TO
REGISTER MY COMPANY AND, THAT
WAS THE SBDC, WHO I GO THROUGH
THE TRAININGS, 1 TO 1 SESSIONS.
AND FINALLY THIS YEAR, I'M
NEAREST STEP TO DO SUCCESS.
THEREFORE MÀ, I'M KINDLY
REQUESTING THE COMMITTEE TO KEEP
GOING THE SERVICE OF THIS BDC
AND EVEN DO NOT GIVING IF IT'S
POSSIBLE TO GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY
OF GROWTH TO SERVE FOR THE
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR MEMBERS
BEVERLY, YOU, ON BEHALF OF
TOYOTA MOTOR NORTH AMERICA, WE
ARE AUTO CAPTIVE FINANCIAL
COMPANY. IN REGARDS TO ISSUE 88,
THIS IS THE BAD DEBT DEDUCTION
AND REFUND. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR WORK WITH YOU ALL
, THE BUDGET COMMITTEE, THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION, AS WELL AS THE
RELEVANT STATE DEPARTMENTS, TO
PRESERVE THIS DEDUCTION. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR WORK ON THE
BUDGET, AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HER CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS ADRIN AND
WORKING. I'M WORKING ON
DEVELOPING AN ENTERPRISE
BUSINESS AND THE HELP THAT SBDC
IS PROVIDING WITH THE DEVELOPING
OF OUR FIRST BUSINESS IS
ENORMOUS. AND I THANK CHAIR
PADILLA, SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS AND SENATOR NIELLO FOR,
ADVOCATING TO FULLY FUND THE TAP
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS.
JEAN HURST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA, THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA,
AS WELL AS THE BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS OF THE COUNTIES OF
ALPINE AND MONO, WE WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION TO
SENATE LEADERSHIP AND TO YOU,
MR. CHAIR, AND THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR INCLUDING
FUNDING TO ADDRESS THE VLF
BACKFILL IN THE THREE COUNTIES
WHO ARE IMPACTED BY INSUFFICIENT
ERAF. IT'S AN IMPORTANT RESOURCE
FOR THESE COMMUNITIES,
PARTICULARLY TINY ALPINE AND
TINY MONO. WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THAT ISSUE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO THE NEXT STEP.
THANKS SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
MORNING, MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JEFF NEEL HERE TODAY. ON BEHALF
OF IMPERIAL COUNTY, WE THANK YOU
FOR, MANY OF THE ITEMS IN THE IN
THE LEGISLATIVE BUDGET, HERE
TODAY TO EXPRESS APPRECIATION
FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT WAS RESTORED, IN
ADDITION TO THE MANY OTHER
THINGS, MR. CHAIR, THAT YOU DO
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY. WE
REALLY APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. I'M ERIC LARA,
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. I'LL SPEAK BRIEFLY ON
THREE ITEMS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
, FIRST, CSAC IS GRATEFUL FOR
THE INCLUSION OF ROUND SIX
FUNDING FOR THE HAP PROGRAM AT
$1 BILLION. WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE UNDERSTANDING THE
CRITICAL NATURE OF THIS FUNDING
TOWARDS MAKING PROGRESS ON OUR
COLLECTIVE HOMELESSNESS EFFORTS,
SECOND, WE APPRECIATE THE
RESTORATION OF SOME FUNDING FOR
THE REAP 2.0 PROGRAM AND ARE
HOPEFUL THAT THE $500 MILLION
PROPOSAL FOR LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDITS WILL BE APPROVED,
FINALLY, CSAC APPRECIATES THE
INCLUSION OF THE $73.5 MILLION
BACKFILL FOR COUNTIES WITH
INSUFFICIENT ERAF. THE PROPOSAL
MEANS THAT THE THREE IMPACTED
COUNTIES WILL RETAIN VITAL
REVENUE AND AVOID CUTS TO CORE
SERVICES. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS JESSE
FLORES. I'M A OWNER OF MEET
MONICA. WE APPLAUD AND THANK
SENATE LEADERSHIP, ESPECIALLY
PRO TEM MCGUIRE AND CHAIR
PADILLA. SENATOR SMALLWOOD,
SENATOR NIELLO AND STAFF OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR THEIR ATTENTION
TO THIS CRITICAL MATTER FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES. I'M OWNER OF
PERUVIAN CRAFT IN OLD
SACRAMENTO. I'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THEM FOR ALMOST TWO, THREE
YEARS AND THANKS TO THEM, A YEAR
AGO I WAS ABLE TO OPEN THIS
BUSINESS. I WANT TO THANK FOR
ALL THE SUPPORT OF THE WORKSHOP,
ALL THE RESOURCES THEY WERE ABLE
TO PROVIDE ME, AND I URGE YOU TO
MAINTAIN THIS FULL FUNDING FOR
TAP INTO FINAL NEGOTIATIONS WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. THANK YOU
. I'D LIKE TO THANK THAT
TESTIFIER FOR PRONOUNCING MY
NAME, THAT THE WAY IT'S
PRONOUNCED IN THE MOTHER COUNTRY
. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS GULZAR
SHIMOZAWA, I'M IN THE PROCESS OF
LAUNCHING A SMALL BUSINESS WITH
SBDC, I WANT TO THANK, THE
SENATE LEADERSHIP AND, THE STAFF
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
MAINTAINING A FULL FUNDING FOR
TOP. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS MIKE MEANS. I'M A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER OF CALTECH
SECURITY, A PRIVATE SECURITY
COMPANY OUT OF ROSEVILLE,
CALIFORNIA. WITHOUT THE SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT CENTER
RESOURCES HELPING ME NAVIGATE
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IN SMALL
BUSINESS WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA,
BUSINESS COMMUNITY. I WOULDN'T
BE AS SUCCESSFUL FULL. SO THANK
YOU FOR CONTINUING THE FUNDING
FOR THIS PROGRAM. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO ME, MY BUSINESS, AND ALL OF
MY EMPLOYEES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. MEMBERS.
CHAIRMAN PADILLA, MEMBERS,
SMALLWOOD, CUEVAS AND SENATOR
NILO, JOIN COUNTY, CALIFORNIA
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE AND ALSO
REPRESENTING OVER 120 ARE OVER
125 MEMBER. CHAMBERS, THE FIRST,
HISPANIC AND BUSINESS
ASSOCIATIONS, THROUGHOUT THE
STATE, WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP, FOR THE
LEADERSHIP OF PRO TEM MCGUIRE,
IN IN REALIZING THAT THIS ITEM
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
SMALL BUSINESS IS REALLY AN
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA, AND
IT'S INVESTMENT IN OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES SO THEY CAN GROW SO
THEY CAN CREATE JOBS SO THEY CAN
BOLSTER THE TAX BASE OF
CALIFORNIA, YOU'VE HEARD THE
STORIES OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS WHO TOOK THE TIME TODAY,
AND WE'RE APPRECIATIVE OF THEM
BEING ABLE TO TAKE AWAY TIME
FROM THEIR BUSINESS. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY, THERE ARE THOUSANDS
OF THOSE STORIES THROUGHOUT ALL
40 DISTRICTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND YOU GUYS SHOULD BE PROUD OF
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE MUST GROW
SMALL BUSINESS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. SO AGAIN, THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR. ANNA
BUCK, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS, I WANTED TO COME UP
TODAY TO SAY THANK YOU FOR ALL
OF YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THE DRE
FEE INCREASE PROPOSAL, WE'VE HAD
REALLY GREAT, CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AGENCY THAT ARE GOING TO
RESULT IN MORE FISCAL
TRANSPARENCY, FOR OUR LICENSEES.
THANK YOU. IT'S BEEN QUITE THE
JOURNEY, BUT THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. THIS IS MARCOS AND
BROOKE MURILLO FROM TOP OF THE
WORLD. I'LL KEEP IT SHORT AND
SWEET BECAUSE WE HAVE TO GET
BACK TO RUNNING OUR RESTAURANT
THAT WAS ABLE TO BE OPEN BECAUSE
OF THE FUNDING AND THE HELP THAT
WE RECEIVED FROM THE SBDC AND
THE CONTINUED SUPPORT THAT WE
HAVE OF FOR GOING FOR YEARS NOW
THAT WE'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS. SO
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR KEEPING
THE FUNDING AND FOR ALLOWING AN
EQUAL PLAYING FIELD FOR EVERY
ENTREPRENEUR TO HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU AND GOOD LUCK. GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS SHELLY. ALEX, I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF SACRAMENTO
VALLEY SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER. MY PROGRAM
SERVES SACRAMENTO, YOLO, YUBA
AND SUTTER. CENTROLEGAL NHIÀU, I
WANT TO PLOT AND THANK SENATE
LEADERSHIP, ESPECIALLY PRO TEM
MCGUIRE AND CHAIR BRIA, SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SENATOR NILO,
AND STAFF OF THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
FOR SUPPORTING THE FULL FUNDING
OF TAB. SBDC IS OFTEN THE FIRST
RESOURCE FOR ENTREPRENEURS
LOOKING TO START A BUSINESS, AND
THE LAST RESORT FOR ACCESS TO
FUNDING. AS MANY OF THE CLIENTS
THAT WE SERVE DO NOT QUALIFY FOR
TRADITIONAL LOANS, OUR ABILITY
TO DO MORE IS MADE POSSIBLE
BECAUSE OF THE SUPPORT FROM TAP
FUNDING, AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
TO DO SO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HELLO, MEMBERS. ELMER LAZARD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION. FIRST, WE WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR WORK ON
THE LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PROPOSAL
THIS YEAR. AND I WANT TO TAKE
THE TIME TO ADDITIONALLY
ADVOCATE FOR INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY AT CAL COMPETES IN
THE OFFICE OF GO-BIZ, WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT AS THESE MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ARE MADE AVAILABLE TO
COMPANIES AND BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA, THAT THEY ARE
CREATING THE HIGHEST QUALITY
JOBS IN THE STATE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. YOU GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
MY NAME IS ANTONIO AGUILAR. I AM
A SENIOR OUTREACH MANAGER AT
SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY, WE'RE A
NATIONAL EDUCATION, RESEARCH AND
ADVOCACY NONPROFIT, I JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR REJECTING
THE PROPOSED CUTS TO THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
YOU KNOW, AS YOU KNOW, MANY
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS, RELY ON THESE LOW COST
RESOURCES. AND SO JUST THANK YOU
FOR MAKING THAT DECISION. THANK
YOU. APPRECIATE IT. ONORABLE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, AMY HINES-IKE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST NETWORK,
FIRST OF ALL, RESPECTFULLY, IT'S
A LITTLE HARD TO BE HERE WHEN WE
KNOW THAT IT'S A FAIT ACCOMPLI
AND YOU'VE ALREADY REACHED A
JOINT DEAL. BUT WE WERE DISMAYED
TO SEE THAT THE FORECLOSURE
INTERVENTION HOUSING
PRESERVATION PROGRAM WAS NOT
PART OF THAT DEAL. I BELIEVE
THAT THE ANALYSIS MENTIONED THAT
IT WAS NOT A TESTED PROGRAM, BUT
PRESERVATION IS A VERY TESTED
STRATEGY THAT PRESERVES OUR
COMMUNITIES IN PLACE AND STOPS
THE DISPLACEMENT OF LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES, SPECIFICALLY PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND THE FOLKS THAT ARE
THE MOST VULNERABLE AND NEED
THAT ASSISTANCE. THE ADDITION
LAYER OF THE FORECLOSURE
INTERVENTION HOUSING
PRESERVATION PROGRAM WAS THAT IT
STRETCHES THE PUBLIC DOLLAR SO
THAT WE CAN ACQUIRE AND
REHABILITATE EXISTING PROPERTIES
AT THE LOWEST POSSIBLE PRICE, SO
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO STRETCH THE
PUBLIC DOLLAR. SO IN THE FUTURE,
IF WE'RE ABLE TO LOOK AT THE
FORECLOSURE INTERVENTION HOUSING
PRESERVATION PROGRAM, WE WOULD
JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT THE PROOF
IS IN THE PUDDING. PRESERVATION
IS AN ESTABLISHED AND TESTED AND
PROVEN STRATEGY, AND THAT THIS
IS THE BEST WAY TO GET MORE BANG
FOR OUR BUCK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, SABRINA
BRADBURY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNCILS OF
GOVERNMENTS ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE'S METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATIONS AND REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
AGENCIES. WE WANTED TO THANK YOU
FOR MAKING REAP 2.0 A PRIORITY
AND RESTORING 250 MILLION OF
THAT FUNDING. MUCH OF THE WORK
HAS ALREADY BEEN UNDERWAY FOR A
COUPLE OF YEARS, AND GETTING
CONTRACTS EXECUTED. SO WE
APPRECIATE YOU ENABLING THIS
WORK TO CONTINUE TO MEET OUR
CLIMATE AND HOUSING GOALS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIR, AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, KIANA VALENTINE WITH
POLITICO GROUP HERE. ON BEHALF
OF A NUMBER OF CLIENTS,
COACHELLA VALLEY ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS, SACRAMENTO AREA
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS, MERCED
COUNTY ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS AND THE TULARE
GOVERNMENTS, ALL GRATEFUL AND
ALIGNING OUR TESTIMONY WITH THAT
OF MISS BRADBURY IN SUPPORT OF
THE RESTORATION OF A MAJORITY OF
THOSE. REAP $2.0 TO ADD TO HER
COMMENTS, I WILL JUST SAY THAT I
HAVE NO DOUBT THAT THIS FUNDING
IS GOING TO BE USED TO DEVELOP
MUCH NEEDED MULTIFAMILY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, CONNECT
CONSTITUENTS TO ADDITIONAL
TRANSIT AND INTERCITY RAIL
OPPORTUNITIES. BICYCLE AND
PEDESTRIAN OPPORTUNITIES, AND
JUST GENERALLY BUILD MORE GHG
REDUCING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR AND
SENATORS. MY NAME IS VANESSA
OROZCO HERE ON BEHALF OF GOLDEN
STATE OPPORTUNITY AND THE CAL
ITC COALITION, I'D LIKE TO SPEAK
ON ITEM 98. WE THANK THE
LEGISLATOR FOR RECOGNIZING THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF THE FREE
TAX PREP ASSISTANCE AND
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH PROGRAMS
BY HELPING TO ADDRESS THE
EFFECTS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PLANNED CUTS IN THE PROGRAM.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE INCREASE IS
NOT GO FAR ENOUGH TO ENSURE OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS CAN OPERATE
THEIR COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
TAX FILING SUPPORT AT THE SAME
SCALE AS THEY HAVE BEEN.
CALIFORNIA HAS LED THE WAY IN
LIFTING FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY
WITH THE EITC AND CTC, BUT THESE
CREDITS ONLY BENEFIT FAMILIES IF
THEY FILE A TAX RETURN. IN
ADDITION, WITHOUT FULLY RESTORED
FUNDING, OUR EFFORTS TO ENROLL
MORE CALIFORNIA IN THE I-10
PROGRAM WILL HAVE TO BE SHELVED.
AT THE TIME WHERE THE WINDOW OF
OPPORTUNITY HAS GROWN, WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT LIFTING THE
MORATORIUM IMPACTING ITIN FILERS
IN THE JANUARY OF THIS YEAR,
CALIFORNIA HAS A CHANCE TO
CAPITALIZE ON THIS WINDOW OF
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS ABLE TO
ACQUIRE AN ITIN. WE ARE EAGER TO
CONTINUE THE COMMUNITY DRIVEN
OUTREACH THAT WE KNOW HAVE A
CLEAR IMPACT ON OUR STATE'S
WORKING FAMILIES. WE URGE YOU TO
TAKE MORE ACTION TO RESTORE FULL
FUNDING SO ALL WORKING FAMILIES
CAN HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
SUPPORTED PROGRAMS. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
DANIELLE BAUTISTA WITH UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIA. HERE ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CAL EITC COALITION
, AS WELL AS GRACE AND END CHILD
POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA FOR SOME
FOREMOST, WE WANT TO EXTEND OUR
DEEPEST GRATITUDE FOR THE
PROPOSED INCLUSION OF 2 MILLION
ONGOING FOR FREE TAX PREPARATION
AND EDUCATION AND OUTREACH. I'M
ECHOING MY COLLEAGUES SENTIMENTS
THAT THIS FUNDING IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURING THAT CALIFORNIANS
ACROSS THE STATE CAN CLAIM TAX
CREDITS SUCH AS THE CAL, ITC,
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT AND
FOSTER YOUTH TAX CREDIT TAX
CREDITS. WE KNOW THAT GO TOWARDS
HOUSING, CHILD CARE, RENT, ETC.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING BRINGING OUR
TOTAL UP TO 12 MILLION. WE
REALLY APPRECIATE IT AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO URGE THAT THERE IS,
A BUDGE INCLUDED FOR 20 MILLION
IN THE NEAR FUTURE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
MARK STIVERS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP. ALSO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM,
THE SAN DIEGO HOUSING
FEDERATION, AND THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT HOUSING, WE ARE VERY
THANKFUL AND URGE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S ADOPTION OF THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE 500 MILLION IN STATE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDITS. ALSO
FOR ADDING A $1 BILLION TO THE
HAP PROGRAM TO FOR HOMELESSNESS
AND RESTORING THE 325 MILLION IN
REVERSIONS FOR THE MULTIFAMILY
HOUSING PROGRAM. THESE RESOURCES
WILL ALLOW US TO KEEP BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND GETTING
HOMELESS PEOPLE INTO SHELTER AND
PERMANENT HOUSING OVER THE NEXT
YEAR. WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS DIVYA
SHIV WITH HOUSING CALIFORNIA, WE
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION
THÀNH FOR RESTORING FUNDING TO
AFFORDABLE AND, HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS SUCH AS HAP AND NCMP.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR CONTINUED
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
HOUSING INSECURITY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
KIM LEWIS, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
SPEAKING ON 63, 76, 64 AND 66.
SPECIFICALLY, I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR INCREASING YOUR
INVESTMENTS IN THE HAP PROGRAM
FOR ROUND SIX AND FOR REJECTING
THE CUTS TO THE HOUSING
NAVIGATION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM, AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON THE TRAILER
BILL, AND HOPING WE CAN FIX THAT
INTERIM HOUSING STUFF FOR OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE. THANK YOU. MARTHA
GUERRERO, REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. REALLY GRATEFUL FOR
THE RESTORATION OF THE REAP 2.0
FUNDING AND THE HOUSING
NAVIGATION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM FOR OUR YOUTH, AND ALSO
FOR THE 1 BILLION IN THE HAP
FUNDING, MUCH NEEDED TO CONTINUE
TO PRESERVE THE, YOU KNOW, THE
PROGRESS WE HAVE MADE IN
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HI THERE,
MCKINLEY THOMPSON MORLEY, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO, I JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS GRATITUDE FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN PROPOSING THE 1
BILLION IN FUNDING FOR ROUND SIX
OF HALF, WHICH IS CRITICAL TO
OUR ONGOING EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
THE HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. ANYONE ELSE PRESENT
WANT TO ADDRESS THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ON ANY OF THE DOCKETED VOTE
ITEMS TODAY? SEEING NO ONE, I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THE COMMITTEE
WILL BREAK OUT, ACTION ON ALL OF
THE ITEMS INTO THREE SEPARATE
GROUPS. BY AGREEMENT WITH THE
OTHER CAUCUS AND SO YOU'LL BEAR
WITH ME AS I READ THROUGH SOME
OF THESE. THE FIRST GROUPING, I
WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION WITH
RESPECT TO ISSUES ONE, THREE,
FIVE, EIGHT, NINE, 11, 12, 13,
15, 16, 17, 18, 20, 21, 23, 24,
Ã 26, 27, 28, 29, 30, 31, 32,
33, 35, 38, 39, 40, 42, 43, 44,
45, 50, 51, 53, 62, 65, 67, 68,
69, 70, 71, 77, 84, 89, 105,
107, A 113, 114, 116, 117, 118,
119, 121, 122, 123, 124, 125,
127 AND 128. I WILL ENTERTAIN.
MOVE BY SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
KRAVIS RECOMMENDATION IS TO
ADOPT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
THÀNH CONSULTANT. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATORS. SENATORS.
PADILLA AYE. PADILLA AYE. NILO.
NILO AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I THANK YOU ON
THAT GROUPING OF ISSUE ITEMS.
THE EYES ARE THREE. THE NO'S ARE
ZERO. THOSE ISSUES ARE OUT. WE
WILL MOVE TO GROUP B, WHICH ARE
ISSUES 224 B AND 63. AND WE'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. MOVE BY
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS ON
THOSE ITEMS. TO ADOPT STAFF
RECOMMENDATION, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATORS PADILLA AYE.
PADILLA AYE. NILO SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
THANK YOU WITH RESPECT TO THOSE
ISSUES. THE EYES ARE TWO. THE
NO'S ARE ZERO. NOT VOTING IS
ONE. THOSE ITEMS ARE OUT. WE
WILL THEN MOVE TO GROUP C. GROUP
C IS COMPOSED OF ISSUES FOUR,
SIX, SEVEN, TEN, 14, 19, 22, 25,
34, 36, 37, 41, 46, 47, 48, 49,
52, 54, 55, 56, 57, 58, 59, 60,
61, 64, 66, 72, 73, 74, 75, 76,
78, 79, 80, 81, 82, 83, 85, 86,
87, 88, 90, 91, 92, 93, 94, 95,
96, 97, 98, 99, 100, 101, 102,
103, 104, 106, 107, B, 108, 109,
110, 111, ONE, 12, ONE, 15, ONE,
21, 26, AND 129. I'LL ENTERTAIN
MOVE BY SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS, WITH RESPECT TO THE
ITEMS IN GROUP C TO ADOPT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR PADILLA
AYE. AYE. NILO. NIELSEN. NØ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS, I THANK YOU. WITH
RESPECT TO GROUP C, THE AYES ARE
TWO. THE NO'S ARE ONE. THOSE
ITEMS ARE OUT WITH THAT. I WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED IN TODAY'S SUB
HEARING AND PROVIDED TESTIMONY.
YOU CAN CONTINUE TO DO SO
THROUGH THE WEB LINK AND DIRECT
TO THE BUDGET STAFF. THANK YOU
ALL AND TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR
YOUR WORK AND PARTICIPATION.
THIS TIME. BUDGET SUB NUMBER
FOUR IS ADJOURNED.